peut-être
le lendemain même de la mort de georges
6-1 groupe sombre réunis autour de
winston churchill et du major akli
attendait l'avion de la princesse
elisabeth devenue reine de grande
bretagne
cependant au château de sandringham des
groupes de visiteurs ému stationnés aux
portes alors que figés dans leur
immobilité 4 garde-chasse des domaines
veillez silencieusement près du cercueil
autour de cet îlot de silence
d'artillerie tonnerre dans toutes les
capitales du royaume
les canes ont salué de 56 coup la mort
de ce souverain de cinquante six ans
[Applaudissements]
et les rites immuables de la succession
royale déroulé leurs fastes
traditionnels
du balcon du palais de st james entouré
de sa suite médiévale de héros et de
poursuivants le roi d'arn visait la
proclamation du nouveau souverain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais en même temps sur les marches de la
bourse
devant la foule qui avait envahi même
les toits les trophées de céramique a
dressé le premier salut à la reine
elizabeth 2
[Musique]
et
god save the queen
les couleurs remontait doma une minute
émouvante passait sur les coeurs
britannique depuis sa naissance au
château de glaris
chacun avait suivi année par année
instant par instant la vie de celle qui
n'était alors que la princesse elizabeth
on avait connu par les photos de
magazines les ors marquantes de sa vie
de petite fille
on avait vu en europe deux coups au
couronnement de son père
un scout girl au milieu de tant de
petites filles anglaises s'y glissent
dans perlé de sueur dans les habits de
sandringham cavalière satisfaite de ses
première chevauchée avec sa soeur
margaret conductrice d'ambulance pendant
la guerre
et toujours aussi simple jeune fille que
dans ces jeux sur le pont du navire qui
l'emporté vers le cas
[Musique]
l'on avait connue plus tard ces visages
heureux d'une jeune épousée
puis ce visage sérieux et doux d'une
jeune mère
[Musique]
elle était devenue pour le peuple
britannique non seulement la fille du
roi les l'héritière de la couronne celle
qui un jour prendrait dans ses mains de
rennes lé destin d'un peuple répartis
sur les cinq continents
[Musique]
sinon qu'elle soit à sandringham les
heures passent et sur un afflux de canon
le roi défunt entre 2 et 2 foule
accourue de toute la province bat par
les chemins de campagne suivi par la
voiture des reines gagné la petite gare
où l'attend le train funèbres
[Musique]
tout le long du parcours des poules sans
deuil figé depuis des heures sur les
talus de la voie
salut ronde un dernier regard ce wagon
fermé qui porta déjà george st
[Musique]
à londres une foule attendait devant les
trois reines le cercueil porté par huit
gardes étaient à nouveau placée sur un
afflux de canon et le cortège
s'ébranlait pour gagner westminster
abbaye où depuis 1900 en bas le coeur de
la nation britannique
ouvert du pavillon royal est sommé de la
couronne le cercueil suivi du de
gloucester père du roi et du duc
d'edimbourg a reçu le silencieux hommage
des mêmes foule qui se pressait voici
quinze ans sur le chemin du couronnement
et c'est toute la peine d'un peuple dont
il avait gagné le coeur qui accompagne
dans ce voyage
celui qui fut georges 6 et qui rejoint
aujourd'hui sous les boudent de
westmister douce qui fut un moment de
l'histoire d'angleterre
[Musique]
pour la sixième fois dans l'histoire
d'angleterre une rennes reçoit la
couronne grande journée pour le monde
britannique qui vit ses plus belles
heures depuis la fin de la guerre partie
de l'opinion palace le carence
historique où on paie place la reine et
le duc d'edimbourg se dirige vers
l'abbaye de westminster entre 2 et d'une
foule elle pour nos vies jamais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un million de spectateurs sont en effet
debout sur le passage du cortège
la plupart ont passé la nuit à leur
place mais la vue du carrosse doré le
visage clair de cette reine de 27 ans
qui symbolise l'avenir britanniques sont
une magnifique récompense
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
devant l'abbaye de westminster rubin
depuis une absence
du royaume d'autres foule aussi dense
aussi haletante
c'est là dans ce sanctuaire que se
résume l'histoire d'angleterre
c'est là que depuis les plus anciens âge
les souverains ce soir la couronne et le
sceptre dans ses apparats médiévale
élise avait 2 va être consacré par la
grâce de dieu hand du royaume-uni de
l'irlande du nord et des dominions dont
delà des mers
elle s'avance maintenant sous les voûtes
de westmister à leurs ombres dorment
tout ce roi guerrier ou poètes qui fit
au long des siècles la grandeur du nom
anglais
lentement entre deux est formé par les
délégués de 72 nations
les proches des plus vieilles familles
d'europe les radjah de l'inde les rois
d'afrique et l'échec d'arabie elle
marche vers le sanctuaire
[Musique]
premier rang le duc d'edimbourg au
centre du coeur le trône antique de
saint-édouard sur lequel furent
couronnés tous les rois d'angleterre est
sur un rythme étrangement lent dans ce
décor coloré où les rois d'armes les
écuyers les chambellans et les pages
s'anime comme les personnages d'une
tapisserie du moyen-âge commencent les
cérémonies qui font d'une souveraine
désigné par les loin une reine marquée
du signe divin
[Musique]
sur l'autel les insignes du pouvoir
resplendissent
tout près des ducs aux royaux la
reine-mère à la tribune royale garde
près d'elle le petit prince charles le
futur ou un instant solennel approche on
devait la reine de la rome impériale et
de la ceinture d'or
la voici prête à recevoir les insignes
du pouvoir
l'archevêque de canterbury l'urml epide
l'état symbole de sa juridiction
temporel dont elle ne devra user qu'eux
pour défendre les opprimés
selon la formule sacramentelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le globe qui s'accompagne des mots
prenez ce globe
et rappelez vous que le monde est soumis
à dieu votre seigneur le sceptre la
croix symbole de la justice et le
sceptre à la colombe symbole de la
miséricorde
[Musique]
et voici l'instant suprême l'archevêque
de canterbury prend la couronne de
saint-édouard sur laquelle étincelles
plus de 1000 pierres précieuses
ils élèvent à la vue de tous et la pose
sur cette tête de 27 ans à ce moment
tous les pères se couvre de leur
couronne médiévale
[Applaudissements]
spectacle étonnant qui veut qu'à
l'époque atomique
les rênes n'est- encore comme en l'an
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à cette souveraine couronné à cette
jeune femme devenue le symbole émouvant
de l'angleterre de tous les temps les
pères d'angleterre vont faire leur
serment de suggestions et de fidélité
quittant le trône de saint-édouard et le
gag à pas lent le trône d'état sur
lequel elle recevra la promesse des
grands de son royaume
[Musique]
et le premier le premier gentilhomme du
royaume
le duc d'edimbourg s'avance mari
d'elisabeth ils savent où le premier
sujet de sa souveraine
[Musique]
sans couronne à genoux les mains jointes
rentrer des mains de la reine
il prononce les mots rituel je suis
votre homme lige dame et de coeur et
c'est toute l'image des décomptes de
chevalerie qui remonte tout d'un coup du
fonds des siècles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est fini au milieu des vivats et
dépend par le cortège s'avance pour la
38e fois le vieux décor de westminster a
bu la couronne descendre sur une terre
précédé des porte étendards parmi
lesquels le maréchal montgomery forte
les couleurs royal précédé des chefs des
gouvernements alliés la couronne venus
d'ottawa de colombo du câble de karachi
ou de canberra dont serine stone
churchill faire de la marche
la reine regagne son carrosse de conte
de fées
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dehors le ciel gris d'une journée
pluvieux mais aussi un peuple qui crie
sa joie de westminster à buckingham
un défilé long de 3 km passe entre 3
millions de spectateurs enthousiastes
par un fantastique où se rencontrent
toutes les couleurs tous les uniformes
tous les climats et tous les âges et qui
forment comme le résumé prestigieux des
fastes du monde britannique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux bambins qui n'y sommes la foule le
rond les barrages
[Musique]
dans ce visage étrangement jeunes que
coiffe une lourde couronne que
cherche-t-il ce peuple est train d'une
émotion singulière l'avenir de
l'angleterre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]